[Música]
las autoridades estadounidenses
revelaron el vídeo en el que la policía
golpea muerte a tyric Nichols una frase
estadounidense de 29 años la familia
pidió justicia al tiempo que el
presidente Joe demostró indignación y
dolor a causa de lo ocurrido
cientos de salvadoreños protestaron en
San Salvador contra la reforma a las
pensiones avalada por el congreso los
ciudadanos aseguran que las
modificaciones solo favorecen a los
fondos privados mientras que dejan a las
personas con una pensión indigna
desde su llegada del poder el presidente
de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva ha
sido enfático en su intención de
relanzar El mercosur un colectivo que
pese a pensárselo contrario en 2021
creció en intercambio comercial Luis
Méndez nos amplía esta información
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos empezamos en
Estados Unidos las autoridades revelaron
el video en el que agentes de la policía
detienen y golpean a tavi Nichols una
afro estadounidense de 29 años que
perdió la vida a causa de las lesiones
crece la indignación y cientos de
personas se manifestaron para pedir
justicia ante lo que ha sido calificado
como un evidente exceso de fuerza
previamente conversamos con Cristóbal
Vázquez corresponsal de France 24 que
nos contó Cuáles han sido las
principales reacciones después de
conocerse el video
Este vídeo además de tres minutos tres
minutos duró esta paliza este
linchamiento que cinco policías
afroamericanos le perpetraron a Cruz él
en el suelo llamaba por su madre llamaba
Socorro a su madre en varias ocasiones y
los abogados describieron esta paliza y
este trato ataúricos como una piñata
humana así le pegaban los policías a
este joven de 29 años que murió tres
días después en un hospital local por
sangrado Severo después de estas heridas
que le perpetraron los policías el
presidente biden también se refirió al
respecto dijo que estaba horrorizado y
con una tristeza profunda de ver esto
que le pasa a los afroamericanos y a las
personas de color en Estados Unidos y
dijo que era un recordatorio
precisamente de los retos que tienen que
enfrentar estas personas de color acá en
Estados Unidos de Cara a esta brutalidad
policial que pues ya salieron
precisamente las de Memphis en las
calles de algunas otras ciudades de
Estados Unidos las personas a
manifestarse el anuncio de la
publicación de este vídeo se había hecho
desde ayer ya la familia lo conocía ya
habían reaccionado de hecho ayer también
en Memphis Tennessee la madre de nicos
pues le dijo a los manifestantes que por
favor lo hicieran de forma pacífica
porque así hubiera sido como el hijo
hubiera querido manifestar sobre un caso
similar En caso de que no hubiera sido
él cientos de personas se manifestaron
en San Salvador en contra de la Reforma
pensional aprobada por el congreso
salvadoreño en diciembre pasado la
modificación involucra seis artículos de
la ley integral del sistema de pensiones
organizaciones aseguran que la reforma
afecta a las personas y solo beneficia a
los fondos privados Ramiro cuevarberena
nos cuenta más
San Salvador fue testigo de la marcha
negra así se denominó la manifestación
de 500 personas en la capital del país
que en ese movilizaron en contra de la
aprobación de seis artículos de la ley
integral del sistema de pensiones
sindicalistas trabajadores y miembros de
organizaciones sociales se dirigieron a
la casa presidencial en oposición a la
reforma Qué es mentira
que lo estamos protestando porque esas
son pensiones miserables para nosotros
además de los trabajadores
organizaciones no gubernamentales
también expresaron su preocupación por
la política de gobierno de nayib bukele
como es el caso del instituto
centroamericano de estudios Fiscales
quien cuestionó los métodos del
ejecutivo y la sustentabilidad
financiera del cambio
para el Instituto las reformas
presentadas por el ejecutivo no dan una
respuesta integrada a los problemas
estructurales del sistema de pensiones
en términos de cobertura suficiencia
equidad y sostenibilidad
esta controvertida legislación forma
parte del paquete presentado por el
gobierno en septiembre de 2021 y que
otorga el manejo de recursos a las
administradoras de fondo de pensiones a
pesar de las solicitudes de
nacionalización de algunos sindicatos
según los datos de sefi 8 de cada 10
personas adultas mayores actualmente no
tienen acceso a una pensión y solo una
de cuatro tienen un trabajo remunerado
que ingresan en el sistema provisional
asuntos no tratados en la reforma la
llegada de Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva al
poder ha potenciado un relanzamiento del
mercosur el bloque compuesto por Brasil
Argentina Uruguay Paraguay que sufrió
una especie de estancamiento durante la
era de Yahir bolsonaro al punto que el
acuerdo con la Unión Europea establecido
en 2019 no ha entrado en vigor para
ampliar esta información me acompañan el
estudio mi compañero Luis Luis es
posible que con el liderazgo de Lula se
pueda recuperar este acuerdo sí
Valentina de hecho ya lo estamos a ver y
para entrar en contexto hay que recordar
que estos bloques establecieron el
acuerdo en 2019 pero no ha entrado en
vigor en parte porque los parlamentarios
del bloque europeo se oponían al acuerdo
por las políticas implementadas por el
ahora expresidente Jair bolsonaro pero
Todo cambió con la llegada de Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva al poder de hecho
ya Charles Michell el presidente del
Consejo europeo le pidió a Lula en días
recientes aprovechar el nuevo panorama
político de América Latina para
concretar el acuerdo comercial de hecho
ante la polémica existente por la
posibilidad de que Uruguay estableciera
un acuerdo unilateral con china el
presidente de Brasil no descartó que
esto sea posible en el futuro pero
durante su encuentro con el presidente
de Uruguay Luis lacalle Pou señaló que
para el mercosur es importante lograr
poner en vigencia el acuerdo con la
Unión Europea previo al establecimiento
de cualquier acuerdo comercial con China
o con otro bloque este acuerdo ha
encontrado trabas refiriéndonos al
acuerdo con la Unión Europea entre otras
cosas por el tema del proteccionismo
recordemos que los países del mercosur
son en su mayoría productores agrícolas
y Allí es donde están centrando su
principales exportación estamos hablando
de soya estamos hablando de carnes entre
otros rubros pero también son estos
productos los que están más protegidos
en los países europeos vale acotar
también el peso político que tienen
estos sectores en Europa pero veamos que
pros y contra tendría este acercamiento
cuando le consultamos al especialista en
economía y profesor universitario
Ricardo rosste
en realidad el problema que tenemos
entre el mercosur y y Europa es que
Europa quiere que se abran las quiero un
Libre Comercio en términos de productos
industriales Argentina y también Brasil
creo están más interesados en
fortalecer el comercio de de productos
agropecuarios y en realidad
políticamente en Europa es bastante
difícil eso porque el sector
agropecuario allá en Europa son
políticamente bastante importantes
Valentina pero Qué significa este
acuerdo para la Unión Europea en primer
lugar acceder a un mercado de 260
millones de personas aproximadamente y a
la quinta economía más sólida fuera de
la Unión Europea con un producto interno
bruto de 2,2 billones de euros en el año
2018 también ingresará a un mercado que
presenta elevadas barreras arancelarias
para el mercosur esto significa pasar de
un 1, cuatro por ciento un veinticinco
por ciento del producto interno bruto
global además que la Unión Europea
eliminará aranceles sobre un 95% de las
importaciones procedentes del mercosur
Luis Pues a usted muchas gracias por
esta ampliación económica aquí en
Francia 24 cambiamos de tema porque la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de Estados Unidos propuso
que los hombres homosexuales o
bisexuales que estén en una relación
monógama o que solo hayan tenido
relaciones sexuales con su pareja
estable Durante los últimos tres meses
puedan donar sangre previamente estas
personas debían esperar un año y luego
tres meses tras su última relación
sexual para ser elegibles previamente
conversamos con Ilan shapiro médico
especializado en salud pública a quien
preguntamos sobre Cuáles son las pruebas
de rigor que se realizan previo a una
donación de sangre para comprobar que la
persona está sana
de entrada Se Checa para h&b todas las
enfermedades importantes que se pueden
transmitir por medio de la sangre esta
idea era en un principio crear y
disminuir los riesgos que una persona al
momento de de darles Esa esa unidad de
sangre para poder estar sanos en este
momento sabemos que tenemos una
disminución de donantes tenemos muchas
cosas que están pasando en el mundo y
sobre todo con Coby 19 muchos de los
bancos de sangre están teniendo
problemas para poder atender eso y por
eso teniendo la evidencia científica y
además la importancia de tener ese banco
de sangre listo para cualquier momento
que cualquier área de nosotros
necesitemos necesitamos ampliar y seguir
ahora sí no no los estereotipos sino lo
que realmente dice la ciencia también
nos dijo si podríamos considerar esta
iniciativa como una forma de luchar
contra el estigmatización
que en forma personal definitivamente
porque una persona que lleva una pareja
sin importancia es hombre hombre mujer
hombre mujer o cualquier definición que
tengamos Pues realmente tiene los mismos
riesgos que cualquier otra persona más
lógicamente Si una persona heterosexual
tiene múltiples parejas también
incrementa su riesgo entonces de esta
manera estamos poniendo algo de de
equidad algo de de Justicia para que
podamos tener todos la misma oportunidad
de donar sangre fin del informativo
volvemos en breve
[Música]